okay
look
up
when you peer at the heavens on a clear
moonless night you can see the stars of
our galaxy strewn across the black
we cannot help but seek recognizable
outlines by tracing our finger from one
star to the next like searching for
shapes in clouds
we see ourselves in the groups of stars
assigning them names and meaning to our
eyes the individual Stars making up
these constellations seem uniform
remarkable only when forming part of a
larger group
but with a powerful enough telescope the
truth reveals itself and we can finally
reshape the sky according to science not
symbolism
so let us take a tour of the Stars
in order of their Rarity
we begin with the failed Stars Brown
dwarfs below eight percent of the mass
of the Sun these are protostars without
the gravitational clout to spark Fusion
in their cores the Galaxy is littered
with these failures one for every
successful star
stars in the prime of their Stellar
lives make up 90 of the several hundred
billion in the Milky Way our sun is one
part of the yellow dwarf category in
which only about seven percent of stars
fall a relative Rarity far more numerous
are the cooler and smaller red dwarfs
that make up a much larger 75 percent as
we look for stars with larger masses the
search becomes more difficult thanks to
their volatility and short lifespan
white supergiants like cannipus the
second brightest star in the sky despite
its great distance from us comprised
less than one percent of the start in
our galaxy and more extreme hypergiants
like the largest known star Stevenson
218 are even harder to find their size
resulting in strong Stellar winds where
Stellar material the mass of Jupiter is
blown away in single events almost
evaporating the star as fast as it grows
While most stars are enjoying their best
life there are tens of billions in the
final stages of their Stellar Revolution
smaller Stars such as the sun will
eventually puff out into red giants a
fleeting midpoint on the way to a white
dwarf these dense and compact Stellar
remnants comprise about five percent of
stars in the present day though
eventually 97 percent of the Milky Ways
Stellar population will shrivel into
these gently fading spheres
neutron stars and black holes are exotic
high density phenomena making up 0.5
percent and point zero zero zero five
percent of our Galaxy's population
respectively and the result of
supernovae by the largest Stars while
spinning neutron stars pulsars have been
observed in their thousands since the
1960s we've only observed 31 of their
most extreme form
natash
this type of neutron star has a magnetic
field a thousand trillion times stronger
than that of the earth and star Quakes
on their surface produce powerful bursts
of gamma rays these star Quakes are also
much stronger than our equivalent
reaching up to 23 on the Richter scale
but even that is still not the rarest
form of star scientists predict could be
out there
in its early days the universe was
filled with hypergiants but they were
much different to those we see now the
first lights that kindled in the cosmos
were vast hungry and short-lived living
and dying in a cosmic blink of an eye
known as population 3 stars they were
the ancestors of us all and they may
still linger out there in the black
the rarest stars in the universe
how much time do you have a plank time
is the shortest possible moment of time
an average human life is about 4 to the
power of 52 of these single moments long
more than the amount of atoms inside the
entire Earth and on average your career
makes up 80 000 hours of that total
roughly 20 percent and so is a huge
opportunity to make a positive
difference in the world eighty thousand
hours has sponsored this video and they
are a non-profit that helps people find
a fulfilling career that also does good
and everything they provide is free
forever based on 10 years of research
with academics from Oxford University
their aim is to help you find a job that
makes a positive difference in the world
helps solve the biggest problems facing
humanity and also gives you job
satisfaction a lot of career advice
focuses on a few well-known paths that
people think have a high social impact
like being a doctor teacher or charity
worker but it turns out these aren't
your only options to be forced for good
and they probably aren't your best
options either everything 80 000 hours
publishes is based on careful
consideration of the best evidence they
can find on the topic their in-depth
research-led career guide has also just
been updated for 2023 and if you join
the newsletter now you'll get a free
copy sent directly to your inbox
so to get started on planning a career
that works on one of the world's most
pressing problems sign up now at eighty
thousand hours dot org forward slash
universe thanks to 80 000 hours for
supporting education on YouTube
[Music]
in Japanese mythology the god of
creation gives birth to many deities but
three a particularly Divine tsukuyomi
the moon God susano the god of Storms
and seas and Amaterasu the goddess of
the Sun the highest deity of all
in the most famous Legend involving the
sun goddess susano threw a holy horse
into a loom flaying it alive and killing
a nearby weaving Maiden Amaterasu was so
upset that she fled and hid in a cave
blocking the entrance
Sun disappeared from the sky and a
permanent night fell on Japan this
eternal night only ended when the other
gods and goddesses staged a ritual
outside the cave laughing so loudly that
Amaterasu could not help but come out to
see what was going on the deities sealed
the cave shut as she emerged and Japan
once again became the Land of the Rising
Sun
[Music]
the sun is essential to all life on
Earth its calm and predictability
nurtures plants animals and humans alike
surrounding them with light and warmth
it is no wonder then that right from
where the earliest civilizations formed
the sun has often been portrayed as a
benevolent God want to be feared perhaps
but only because of its possible
disappearance
now of course we understand that stars
are physical entities still full of
wonder but explainable using modern
science
for the longest time we were reliant on
only our own eyes until Galileo ground
his artificial lenses and magnified the
skies with his telescope
the haze of the Milky Way resolved into
millions of stars and even some
individual Stars revealed themselves to
be binary systems hundreds of years
passed and we cataloged the positions of
these stars with increasing accuracy and
with the Advent of spectroscopy we could
even begin to identify barcodes
individual to each star the gaps in
which revealed which heavy elements were
present in that Stellar atmosphere
we could identify what these distant
Suns
were really made of
but that was not all
[Music]
chemical elements comprise a nucleus
surrounded by electrons these electrons
naturally rest in the ground state but
can be excited up into different energy
levels by the absorption of a photon
with an energy equal to a particular
energy gap
as photons of all energies struggle from
the core of a star through its outer
layers chemical elements within the star
will absorb photons with energies equal
to each element's specific electron
energy gaps
the energy of a photon is proportional
to its wavelength and so photons of
certain energies certain wavelengths
absorbed by certain elements in their
escape from the sun will be missing when
they reach out telescopes
our sun emits light across the
electromagnetic spectrum peeking in the
green wavelengths with its spectrum is
full of gaps absorption lines that tell
us what elements are present and also
the temperature of the Stellar
atmosphere absorption lines attributed
to a specific element have been measured
in Laboratories and are the same
wherever we observe them in the universe
except for one key feature they vary
according to temperature higher
temperatures result in the excitation
and release of electrons changing the
energy gaps and so the pattern
and this means that we can use the color
of a star to figure out how hot it is
in the 1860s Italian astronomer Angelo
seki was one of the first to defied
Stars into categories based on
spectroscopy noticing that stars of
similar color have similar Spectra
cooler stars are red the lower energy
end of the spectrum and blue stars are
hotter
and so finally there was a way of
grouping the Stars other than imagined
patterns because of their apparent
closeness
but at the turn of the 20th century
teams of women at the Harvard
Observatory went one step further known
as the Harvard computers they were
methodically studying thousands of glass
plates per day small sections of the
night sky were imprinted on the glass a
tiny Spectra accompanying each star
women such as Annie Jump Cannon and
Willamina P Fleming had initially been
hired as cheaper labor but their
knowledge of the Skies was unsurpassed
soon a system was created whereby stars
were sorted into alphabetical categories
according to the features in their
Spectra over time with more
understanding of the physical processes
determining absorption lines these
categories were reorganized and merged
into the categories that persist today
OB AF GK MN often remembered using the
mnemonic who be a fine guy kiss me now
foreign
ERS had created a system to organize the
stars above but they still believed they
were all fundamentally the same
differing only in temperature even
including planets in this approximation
after all the Spectra of the sun showed
the presence of elements found on Earth
carbon oxygen and iron
bread is bread whether heated or toasted
it is the similarity of ingredients that
defines it until 1925 the Earth was seen
as simply the cold end of a temperature
classification of stars
the sun was just a hot Earth
this was because astronomers had mainly
been focusing on the presence or absence
of a chemical's barcode not how much of
that element might actually be present
this required a far more complicated
calculation where the relative
ionization States of each element would
need to be taken into account
and it wasn't until 1925 when
british-born astronomer Cecilia Payne
finally did that calculation that the
true interior of our local star
was revealed
[Music]
she determined the mass of the Sun to be
98 hydrogen the heavy elements just a
garnish the ingredients of stars and
planets were largely the same but the
relative amounts of these ingredients
were completely different there was no
way that these two entities could be of
the same category this result however
ranso counter to establish knowledge
that Payne's thesis was not accepted in
the scientific world and she eventually
moved on from the subject indeed even
she wasn't entirely sure of her idea
until it was independently confirmed
four years later her Limelight lost her
moment gone
to quote pain do not undertake a
scientific career in quest of fame or
money there are easier and better ways
to reach them
and so once again the perspective
shifted stars were not Gods but they
were not hot planets either there was
something unique superheated balls of
gas releasing enormous amounts of energy
there now existed two categories planets
and stars with the latter subdivided by
temperature
garnish of heavy elements present in the
sun was not to be discounted for it
would be the key to Breaking the
remaining assumption that all stars were
the same
[Music]
in the 1940s Walter barde noticed
differences in the Stella Spectra from
stars in different locations in the
Galaxy the dust had only just settled
after the split of stars and planets and
now barday was proposing a further split
within the Stars
now Galaxy spiral were still in
nurseries were prevalent the Spectra of
the young Stars had stronger absorption
lines indicating a larger abundance of
heavy elements these he named population
1 a category that includes our sun
in the Ethereal Halo of the Milky Way
however the Spectra suggested the Stars
contained fewer heavier elements this
Halo is the retirement home of the Milky
Way they were named population 2.
but that was not the end for even though
Stars still contained some heavy
elements they were not totally
unpolluted
and so the question then good were there
even purer Stars hiding out there in the
depths of space
was there an even older population
waiting
to be found
[Music]
in 2022 a team of astronomers from John
Hopkins University was scouring images
from the Hubble's Space Telescope the
hints of the earliest galaxies when they
found something totally unexpected
Hubble has produced beautiful images of
nearby galaxies in intricate detail
pinwheels galaxies bright with star
formation and even galaxies colliding
but as we look farther away and thus
further back in time the images become
increasingly murky smudges of
ill-defined color
however as the scientists peered at one
of these distant galaxies they noticed a
pinprick of detail a single star clearly
picked out from the amorphous background
Galaxy almost as if it had been lined up
with a magnifying glass
it was named Arendelle or Morningstar in
Old English and was calculated to have
been born less than a billion years
after the big bang
[Music]
believed to have been between 50 and 100
solar masses with a surface temperature
of 20 000 Kelvin over three times hotter
than our sun we would not normally be
able to see a star so far away but here
we were lucky for there had been a
chance alignment with a cosmic
magnifying glass a gravitational lens
massive clusters of galaxies produce
such a large gravitational pull that the
light from background stars is bent
around the cluster just like light bends
along with the lens shape in a
magnifying glass
stars and galaxies that would otherwise
be hidden behind the cluster of
foreground Galaxies have their light
projected and magnified around the
cluster
astronomers use this effect
gravitational lensing to see objects to
faint or too far away to see otherwise
but of course we cannot choose what to
magnify that is up to luck and the
chances of a single star so precisely
aligning with the focus of the lens were
astonishingly small for Arendelle the
Galaxy cluster had magnified and
distorted its host Galaxy into an arc
typical of a strong lensing effect
its image had been enhanced a thousand
times over making it seem bigger and
brighter than all the stars in the
galaxy surrounding it
this wasn't a new phenomenon indeed
Einstein had predicted it at the
beginning of the 20th century but there
was something else about Arendelle that
left the astronomers in shock
color
of its light
has unique properties depending on its
energy the electromagnetic spectrum
stretches from low energy long
wavelength radio waves through the
infrared a rainbow of optical light and
up to the high energy shorter wavelength
UV X-rays and gamma rays
when a source of light is moving away
from us we observe the Starlight is
shifted down the Spectrum to longer
wavelengths because of the expansion of
the universe the light we are observing
is of lower energy redshift
the expansion of space-time is such that
we observe further galaxies as traveling
at faster speeds away from us thus we
will see larger redshifts from the
farthest galaxies that are moving the
fastest away
and arendelle's light was very red
indeed placing it at a vast distance the
light from this star had taken 13
billion years to get to us placing it
close to the era of the first Stars
yet despite its light living on
stretched across the Galaxy spanning
lens distant Arendelle itself is no more
the eventual fate of a star depends only
on its mass a star dies when gravity
wins the fight against the pressure
created by the atoms in the core of the
star here the immense gravitational
pressure causes hydrogen to fuse into
helium releasing energy and heat
balancing the inwards force once the
hydrogen in the core has been all used
up the core contracts and the fusion of
helium begins while the fusion of
hydrogen proceeds outwards in a shell
surrounding the core for stars below
eight solar masses the outer layers of
the star inflate in a balancing act with
the Contracting core and the star grows
to become a red giant
when the sun evolves into a red giant in
5 billion years it will envelop the
orbits of mercury venus and possibly
Earth
in these smaller Stars which
nevertheless comprise 97 of the Stellar
population of the Milky Way the
temperature in the core is not
sufficient to fuse carbon and so a core
of inert carbon builds up the fusion
reactions stop and the outward pressure
provided by the energetic products of
these reactions suddenly drops like a
tug of war where one opponent lets go
the opposing gravitational force pulls
the outer layers collapsing the star
into a white dwarf a Stella Remnant held
up by the pressure of the electrons in
the atoms
but for stars with a higher Mass a more
violent end awaits
above 10 solar masses the temperature is
high enough that Fusion can proceed
through increasingly heavier elements a
cross-section of the star would show a
core of inert iron surrounded by shells
created by the outwards progression of
fusion of lighter elements when it comes
to the formation of iron though Fusion
is no longer so energy efficient the
fusion of iron consumes more energy than
it gives resulting in another sudden
loss of pressure this time the mass of
the collapsing shells is so great as to
overcome the electron pressure that
holds up the layers in a white dwarf the
star continues collapsing to an even
denser remnant
neutron star
this ultra dense mass of neutrons
finally provides the force necessary to
stop the gravitational collapse
the event is so sudden though that there
is no gentle release of the outer layers
into a planetary nebula this time there
is a bright explosion a supernova where
all but the neutron star Remnant
explodes into the surroundings
thank you
the truly massive stars tens of solar
masses will leave remnants that
following the Supernova are still too
massive to compete against their own
gravitational collapse
gravity wins completely the neutron star
collapses in on itself and forms a black
hole a point in space-time so dense that
even light cannot Escape its
gravitational pull
foreign
all these outcomes depend on mass and
result in counter-intuitively shorter
lifetimes the more massive the star the
more massive the star the more hydrogen
fuel there is and so one would think the
longer this process can continue however
the more hydrogen the more gravitational
pressure the star is under and the
faster the fusion process needs to
progress to create a higher pressure
the more massive the star the shorter
the lifetime and the more violence it is
met with at the end
arendelle's mass is such that we know it
would have perished in a supernova
within millions of years of its birth
and these supernovae are key to our
understanding of the different
populations of stars population 1 and
population 2. the explosion spreads the
newly created heavier elements into the
surrounding gas which when it cools will
go on to form the next generation of
star
Walter barde had found two distinct
populations with different heavy element
content but this was not a transition
over a stellar lifetime it was an
evolution of the properties of stars
over the universe's lifetime
generations of Stellar formation death
and rebirth were creating stars with
increasing levels of heavy elements two
populations of Stellar Evolution are as
divergent and yet related as the mammoth
and the Elephant
[Music]
over generations of stars more heavy
elements are created and spread into the
interstellar medium through powerful
supernovae successive generations of
stars form from richer gas and so begin
their lives already composed of a lower
fraction of hydrogen astronomers could
follow this timeline easily enough but
it left them
with a question
what if we continue looking back into
the darkness rewinding time from
population 1 to population 2 and further
such that the stars were made from purer
and purer gas
there must have been a common ancestor
born to a universe so new and untouched
that it was made of just hydrogen and
helium but for scattering of lithium and
beryllium the only other two elements
around after the big bang
with these the first primitive Stars
where was population three
the light from Arendelle is ancient but
there are enough hints of heavy elements
that it is unlikely to be of the oldest
generation of stars though only further
observations of its Spectrum by the
James Webb Space Telescope will tell us
for sure
and the observation of Arendelle was
already record-breaking it didn't just
improve on the previous record for
farthest star observed it smashed it to
smithereens
and it might be a record that is here to
stay the light from Arendelle is so
faint that had it not been so perfectly
aligned with the cosmic lens we would
not have seen it at all and there is no
guarantee that we will chance upon
another galaxy cluster with a similarly
serendipitous alignment
even if we were so lucky stars any
farther away than Arendelle and so from
an earlier time might be too faint to
see even with lensing
much closer to home back amongst our
constellations we can dive into the
Orion Nebula and see how modern day
stars come to life it is a dynamic
environment full of the gas and dust
needed to form nascent Suns but despite
this nebula being a typical Stellar
Nursery the surroundings are nothing
like those that created the first Stars
they would have been born into a very
different universe
population 3 came into being in a more
primitive calmer environment
pure Darkness
[Music]
about 100 million years after the big
bang There was just hydrogen and helium
a smidgen of lithium but no trace of the
heavier elements
this simple gas gathered together under
its own gravity following the
scaffolding of Dark Matter hidden
throughout the Universe
forming a star is a Precision process if
a gas cloud is too small Fusion cannot
ignite and the gas cloud is doomed to
become a brown dwarf a failed star if a
gas cloud is too hot then the collapsing
Cloud will meet resistance from the gas
pressure and end up dispersing any gas
will naturally heat as the cloud
collapses and pressure increases just as
your bike tire becomes warm when
inflating somehow this energy must be
carried away to prevent the cloud
dispersing but not in such an explosive
way as to reverse the collapse
in the Orion Nebula the gas is Rich with
heavy elements collisions between the
atoms within the gas cause electrons to
climb up the energy levels releasing
photons as they naturally descend again
these photons are free to flee the
system packets of energy that were once
embodied in the kinetic energy and
pressure of the gas
the heavy elements have many energy
Transitions and losing energy in this
way is easy in the primordial Universe
however the stars must make do with the
energy levels available in hydrogen and
helium the energy loss is far less
efficient and so clouds more easily
disperse as they collapse only the truly
massive clouds can produce the
gravitational pressure that could
sustain collapse throughout that
inefficient heat loss
gently gently these lucky clouds
collapse until the pressure in the core
is so high as to start the process of
fusion
[Music]
first stars begin their lives as Giants
battling the constant pressure of
gravity fusing hydrogen and releasing
the photons that light up the universe
for first time
but just like Arendelle these massive
first stars are long gone our sun will
have a lifetime of approximately 9 to 10
billion years of which it is halfway
through in comparison the first stars of
a hundred times the mass of our sun will
live a few million years at most
it is the three-day life of a fruit fly
compared to that of humans
of course the light of population 3 is
still traveling across the expanding
universe but it is too faint for us to
make out without the chance
magnification of a gravitational lens
[Music]
and so are we doomed to place our hopes
on another such serendipitous alignment
is this old light all that is left is
all we can do
wait
Stellar archaeologists
aren't so sure
and they go further they believe we can
not only observe the old light of long
Dead first Stars
but the first Stars
themselves
[Music]
over 500 000 years ago on the island of
Crete there once lived a population of
mammoths
mammoths are extinct victims of a change
in the climate and hunting by early
humans but we have learned about their
importance in prehistoric human life
through cave art
rufiniak cave a UNESCO world heritage
site is known as the cave of 100
mammoths mammoths account for 70 of the
animals depicted and looking at the
simple lines of their tusks and bodies
it's easy to see why these extinct
creatures still hold our fascination
they were daunting beasts reaching about
4 meters in height a species where
gigantism was normal
but not
concrete
on several islands around the world
Island life encouraged these mammals to
evolve smaller and smaller bodies we use
the word Mammoth colloquially to mean
anything gigantic or outsized yet the
pygmy Mammoth of Crete reached only one
meter high insular dwarfism is a
well-known evolutionary effect whereby
species evolve smaller versions of their
bodies to fit in with a smaller
environment most often on an island
pygmy mammoths existed in Pockets around
the world while Mammoth skeletons are
common in museums the bodies of these
miniature mammoths are far rarer because
of their lower numbers
and so too the first stars were mammoths
by nature but just like the evolution of
life on Earth the quickly changing
Universe led to pockets of smaller pygmy
population three stars
and the smaller Mass means a longer
lifetime so if we search the islands
where they still live we might just find
one
foreign
as the first Stars die they explode and
Seed the pristine Universe with heavier
elements
no longer just hydrogen helium and
lithium but beryllium carbon and oxygen
the ingredients for planets and life
so efficient is this seeding that the
first generation of population three
stars is also the last only a few
million years after the darkness ended
no corner of the universe remains
pristine population 3 the primordial
Stars can no longer form
but why should we care about these first
Stars why not just study those close to
us that still live and are easily
observed
first they help complete our knowledge
of modern day Stellar astronomy
population 3 stars are chemically so
different to their modern day
counterparts the diffusion reactions and
energy transfer processes that power
them are quite unlike what we see in
stars like our sun
ly the first stars were responsible for
the greatest chemical Evolution event
our universe has ever seen a sudden
spark that began billions of years of
heavy element manufacture
and last of all simple curiosity these
stars are extinct the window of their
existence was a cosmological blink of
the eye a few million years over 13
billion years ago
they are a dinosaur a Dodo a mammoth
imbued with a mystery astronomers can't
resist
their short lifetimes however would
appear to leave little hope for
observation
except for the fact like mammoths stars
form over a range of sizes
massive stars do indeed dominate in this
time as a rule but every rule has an
exception just as our time sees small
Stars dominate with few massive stars
the era of the first Stars may have
contained many massive stars with a
sprinkling of smaller
and astronomers have only been equipped
to consider the possibility of these
smaller stars in the last few years
through more and more powerful computer
simulations
accurately simulator star formation
region you need an n-body Dark Matter
simulation coupled with a way to
calculate the physics of the gas n-body
simulations are so called because they
apply physical equations to a certain
number n of discrete Mass particles in
the simulation space
imagine a room of 25 people these people
are interacting all the time moving
between conversations clustering around
particularly entertaining individuals
breaking off into groups in a low mass
resolution and body simulation we might
have only five particles so we would
have to represent five humans per
particle we wouldn't be able to capture
the smaller movements of the individual
only the larger movements of the groups
whereas in a high mass resolution
simulation we could perhaps apply a
particle for each human picking up all
the interactions but this will be a far
more complex calculation and so if we
are restricted to five particles but
interested in how an individual
conversation plays out we might perhaps
choose to zoom in instead assigning one
particle per human but focusing only on
one group of five
and so in simulations of star formation
regions the movement of the Dark Matter
particles under complex gravitational
interactions is calculated over time
steps to find the scaffolding upon which
the hydrogen comes together you then
have the choice to either run accurate
hydrodynamical simulations which
calculate the movement and physics of
the gas in a similar manner assigning a
certain number of particles or make
sweeping assumptions and model the gas
physics analytically with a few short
equations applied generally to the whole
box
for a long time it was assumed
analytically that all the gas in the
area surrounding a protostar would over
the course of thousands of years accrete
onto the star leaving nothing else it
was assumed the first Stars would be
lonely however more recently computing
power is such that we can use some of
the biggest supercomputers in the world
to run simulations with a finer Mass
resolution over the region surrounding
the protostar
foreign these simulations have revealed
a disc of matter that flattens like a
pancake when the cloud collapses and
rotates like a chef spinning pizza dough
this accretion disk of gas and dust is a
crowded turbulent environment causing
the disk to fragment
astronomers then applied a final Mass
resolution to some of these smaller
knots of gas zooming in only on them
they saw that over thousands of years
the turbulent environment allows the gas
to efficiently lose heat and collapse to
form smaller Stars around the massive
Central Star sometimes there was just
one sometimes there were up to 50. most
of the mass was still concentrated
within that Central Star but these
intricate simulations surprised Everyone
by suggesting the leftover gas could
form far less massive stars
this Revelation was of great consequence
to those seeking the first Stars
according to the mass lifetime relation
those smaller sibling Stars could live
for billions of years if population 3
stars were formed with only a mere 80
percent of the mass of our sun or less
then according to that relation they
would have been able to live for over 13
billion years
could still be alive
today
and moreover some of them might even
have been swept up into our galaxy as it
formed from the collisions of smaller
galaxies
but if these stars do exist finding them
will be no easy task
these small population 3 stars would be
extreme Rarities among the hundreds of
billions of stars in the Milky Way
ancient Treasures to be sought amongst
the common modern reproductions
they would also not have led a tranquil
life
over 13 billion years they would have
experienced the pollution of their
surroundings by the deaths of their more
massive siblings the formation of the
Next Generation population 2.
first galaxies 2 would have formed
around them and violently merged with
other galaxies mixing the populations of
stars
and so how could we possibly find these
first Stars the key again
license spectroscopy
within the spectrum of these first Stars
would be signatures that could not be
forged their light should be clean of
the absorption lines of heavier elements
their rainbow Spectrum only revealing
hydrogen and helium in their atmospheres
however spectroscopy is not cheap or
quick assessing every Star would be like
launching a full paleontological survey
of every square meter of Europe Mainland
included hoping to find the bones of
those isolated island-dwelling mammoths
so we must narrow our search to the
regions the islands in the sky most
likely to host what we seek
to provide further complication their
pristine bodies are likely covered in
billions of years of pollutants heavy
elements that have accreted onto their
surfaces as the universe changed around
them creating false lines in their
Spectra and so to determine the
difference between population 3 and
population 2 requires careful and
intensive work this is archeology in the
truest sense of the word uncovering
evidence of the past by dusting off the
layers of dirt
the Milky Way comprises three Stellar
components the disc the Bulge and the
Halo the disc is Young with star
formation dense with population 1 and no
place for an old star to retire
the Bulge is the oldest component of the
Galaxy and is the most obvious to search
except that it is also crowded with
young stars and so shrouded in dust that
peering into it is an almost impossible
task
and so that leaves the Halo
the Halo is the most diffuse of the
three components a low density area to
which stars naturally drift over time
there are fewer stars to sort through
here and there is a natural minimum age
making it more likely to find what we're
looking for most Stellar archeology has
concentrated on the Halo narrowing the
search considerably but not solving the
issue of camouflage these old population
three stars do not dress their age
they cover themselves as their
descendants would giving the impression
Upon A cursory glance that they contain
the heavy elements like younger
populations
the disguise is not perfect though there
are telltale signs of age such that we
don't need to examine the full Spectra
in fine detail
at least at the start
iron is a strong line in the Spectrum
and not as easily faked by external
pollution Stellar archaeologists
initially use iron as a proxy for all
Heavy elements and can take crude
Spectra which first evaluates the
strength of this line only we can scan
quickly looking for stars with the
faintest iron lines and in this smaller
sample of candidates we can afford to
look again at a higher wavelength
resolution checking the disguise more
carefully using computer models
astronomers can estimate the effect of
billions of years of camouflage and work
out what abundances we should expect if
this is a polluted pristine star
the Ultimate Prize is the spectrum that
shows no sign of heavy element
absorption lines when these allowances
are considered and dusted away
as we hone our techniques and sift
through the Sands we have become more
expert at quickly tossing Out The Fakes
and separating the oldest Stars
in 2013 a detailed look at the Spectrum
of a star labeled
sm03136708 reveals no trace of an iron
line at all while we couldn't rule out
the presence of iron below the natural
light noise of the telescope this was an
exciting discovery
sadly though while iron is the robust
first indicator of the age of a star a
closer look at the disguise of this star
still revealed for faint heavy elements
though so few that modeling showed it
formed from the detritus of only one
supernova
this was a star that had formed directly
from the remnants of population 3.
a first descendant
by looking at the abundances of those
first few heavy elements and the mass of
the new Star scientists determined that
the population 3 star before it was a
star 60 times the mass of our sun it
likely died in a relatively low energy
Supernova such that few heavy elements
from the core escaped before it settled
into a black hole
and so while
sm-0313 is agonizingly close to a
pristine first star
it isn't quite there
the search continues
[Music]
if we find a first star in the Milky Way
it will be a pygmy there is no other way
for it to have survived so long it would
tell us a lot about primordial chemistry
and pollution by heavy metals but it
would not tell us as much about the true
mammoths that ruled the skies
to learn about these the long dead giant
first Stars
we will have to be more creative
imagine looking up at the night sky
perusing the constellations you know so
well and finding a star is missing
perhaps Cassiopeia is no longer a w or
maybe a Ryan's sword is shorter
among the 5 000 Stars you can see would
you miss
just one
in 2015 astronomers were carrying out a
survey and encountered this very dilemma
the team were taking new images of the
sky and comparing them to previous
snapshots
there are naturally variable stars
flashing and pulsing and there are
sometimes bright supernovae marking the
end of a star but
n6946bh1 was neither of these
no one had marked this star out as
special or worthy of continuous
observations and so it was observed only
infrequently prior to 2009 observations
at that location had shown a red
hypergiant 25 times the mass of the Sun
but in 2009 the star had appeared far
brighter jumping from a hundred thousand
times as luminous as the sun to a
million times this continued for at
least three months but the next
observation was in 2015.
and by then
it was gone
there was no sign of a star and there
was no sign of a supernova the end point
that theory predicted for this star even
when a black hole forms it does so after
the Supernova event the remnant of which
lingers in the area for years
n6946bh1 had simply disappeared between
observations
follow-up infrared observations showed a
faint glow where
n6946bh1 should be but it was far too
faint to belong to a supernova Remnant
instead it has been suggested that it
came from the outer layer of the star
ejected in the final moments before a
black hole formed at its core
dense core collapsed in on itself a
shock wave rippled outwards forcing some
Stellar material out into the wider
environment away from the immediate
clutches of the black hole if this
indeed is the correct scenario as
further studies up to current data
supported then this is the first time we
have witnessed a black hole forming
n6946bh1 is the best candidate
astronomers have for what is termed a
failed Supernova a phenomenon theorized
to solve some pressing problems in
Stellar evolutionary theory
the rate of large star formation is
greater than the rate of supernovae
suggesting that these hypergiant stars
must be dying in a different way however
hypergiants are so rare that sample
sizes have often been called into
question and this is where the mammoth
first Stars would come into their own
the era of the first stars were we to
catch a glimpse of it would provide a
playground for those working on theories
applicable to modern day giant stars and
more than that this rare Stellar death
is strikingly similar to that which we
think the largest of the first Stars may
have experienced
the exchange of knowledge between those
studying ancient and modern stars is
two-way
if we have indeed observed a black hole
forming without a supernova in the
modern Universe it makes it even more
likely they formed in the past too
sometimes in the early Universe clouds
of gas were so large that their lives
flashed by in an instant
they collapsed with such force that
Fusion didn't have a chance to fight
back and the Stellar stage is skipped
entirely these direct collapse black
holes are thought by some to have ceded
the supermassive black holes at the
center of spiral galaxies all around us
including our own a potential solution
to the decades-old mystery of how these
gigantic black holes got so large
and so having modern day analogues
whether in the way they live or the way
they die is vital to our understanding
of the past
many Mammoth that explorers have
uncovered are so well preserved Under
Ice that their hair and even some of
their flesh is intact to the extent that
there are stories of explorers feeding
Mammoth meat to their dogs and even
tasting it themselves the presence of
soft tissue has led to the suggestion
that scientists could resurrect the
species from Extinction but the DNA is
ancient and extremely fragment tree
putting it together into full sequence
is challenging and can so far only be
helped along using the Genome of their
modern day counterparts
elephants
so in space we can study extremely
massive stars such as cannipus and
Beetlejuice modern day elephant Stars
similar enough to share many of their
characteristics with the long dead
Mammoth first stars for example the
strength of the radiation and magnetic
fields in a gigantic star conspire to
cause strong Stellar winds so strong
that they can carry off large amounts of
mass steadily evaporating the star and
population 3 was similarly likely to
have strong Stellar winds only
accelerating their inevitable and quick
demise
but while there is hope for finding a
low mass first star in our neighborhood
or learning from Modern Day versions the
search for the truly representative
massive first Stars can only occur by
looking for them directly and the signal
they have left behind
and though this is not an impossible
task it isn't easy
[Music]
of course they are long dead
but they all left a mark on their
environment
Fierce Stellar winds and strong UV light
of the first Stars ionized any hydrogen
gas surrounding them knocking electrons
loose from hydrogen atoms and forming
bubbles of ionized hydrogen in a sea of
neutral hydrogen
and this neutral hydrogen that which
isn't affected by the first Stars emits
radiation at a very specific wavelength
21 centimeters
this is because of what is known as a
spin flip transition this occurs between
the proton and electron in the hydrogen
atom all particles have a property
called spin when an electron has the
same direction spin characteristic as
the proton it occupies a higher energy
level when that spin changes to be in
the opposite direction however the
electron must fall into a lower energy
level the energy difference is lost as a
photon with a wavelength of 21
centimeters these 21 centimeter photons
travel across the universe and land on
radio telescopes on Earth
but when a photon from a first star
ionizes a hydrogen atom the electron is
released breaking the interaction with
the proton and stopping production of 21
centimeter radiation this means that if
we were to construct an image of what a
radio telescope scanning the sky for 21
centimeter radiation could see it would
look like a slice of Swiss cheese with
the holes representing the bubbles of
ionized hydrogen and the ionized
hydrogen representing the first Stars
these bubbles merge quickly however and
it's not just the first stars that can
ionize hydrogen black holes can create
bubbles too though not as spherical and
neat and galaxies made of population 2
Stars can produce so many photons that
before long the entire universe is one
large bubble of ionized hydrogen
this transition is called the epoch of
reionization and the shape of these
Bubbles and the speed at which they
appear and merge tells us about what was
in the universe
and so while we may not see the first
Stars we can tell by their Footprints
where they have been and how they grew
and lived
radio telescopes such as the square
kilometer array are observing this 21
centimeter radiation and map these
bubbles trying to infer the populations
of the first stars and their
interactions
but that is not the end of it for we can
also detect the footprints of their
deaths
if truly massive stars of about a
thousand times the mass of the sun do
form then they will collapse so fast
that they immediately form a black hole
a direct collapse black hole if two of
these entities were to become captured
in their Mutual gravity then they would
orbit one another steadily losing energy
and in spiraling before an eventual
Collision the energy lost in this
process is converted into gravitational
waves ripples in space-time caused by
the movements of these two space-time
distorting monsters in 2016 ligo and
Virgo confirmed the first ever
observation of gravitational waves as
the result of a black hole merger the
signal from ancient direct collapse
black hole mergers will be far weaker
due to their distance requiring more
Advanced Equipment Lisa is a planned
NASA and esa's space-based gravitational
wave Observatory that will continuously
monitor the exact distances between
three space stations if a gravitational
Ripple passes through these distances
change allowing us to detect the waves
the size and frequency of these waves
give us a lot more information about the
objects that have merged meaning we
would know a little more about the
higher end of the mass scale of the
first Stars how many there were and
their maximum Mass
but direct collapsed black holes are the
theoretical Destiny of only the most
massive first Stars most will end their
lives in intense explosions called pair
instability supernovae these will have
been some of the brightest explosions in
the universe and there is a small chance
that a telescope like James Webb will
capture one that has been lensed in the
same way as Arendelle it is however
another long shot as these lensing
events are vanishingly rare
the brightness of the Supernova does
make it a possibility however whereas
the light of the first Stars themselves
is too far and too faint for us to ever
see directly
and so we have so many methods in play
from scanning the skies for the pygmy
population threes to analyzing the 21
centimeter signal of the first massive
stars
from capturing gravitational waves of
black hole collisions to picking apart
modern Mammoth counterparts like
Beetlejuice
we have a long list of avenues to pursue
though similar beasts roam the Galaxy
today none are quite as unique as those
first mammoths stars that first lit up
the darkness
star switch in the cosmological blink of
an eye change the course of the universe
irreversibly yet died so quickly they
never got to see the diversity of
structure and life that they sparked
you've been watching the entire history
of the universe don't forget to like And
subscribe and leave us a comment to tell
us what you think
thanks for watching I will see you
next time
foreign